réréaménager les espaces verts.
LeLes parties sont plus rares pr
exexemplple.
ReReportage de Lily Bachand.
- - Le club de golf de Candiac
a a fermé ses portes en 2019.
C'C'est maintenant un promoteur
imimmobilier qui en est
prpropriétaire, alors que
plplusieurs citoyens,
cocomme Yves Couturier, veulent
àà tout prix préserver
cecet espace vert.
YVYVES COUTURIER, président,
ReRegroupement des résidents
- - C'est de laisser un legs
auaux générations futures, parce
quque si on commence à construie
papartout, bien, on n'aura plus
dede nature, on n'aura plus rie.
- - Il se réjouit du règlement
adadopté par la communauté
mémétropolitaine de Montréal,
ququi bloquera tout développemet
susur six terrains de golf :
ceceux de Candiac, Chambly,
BeBeloeil, Rosemère, Terrebonne
etet Mascouche. Des terrains
ququi totalisent 284 hectares en
mimilieu urbain, où les espaces
veverts se font de plus en plus
rarares.
NONORMAND DYOTTE, maire de Candc
- - Cet espace-là, qui est
enen plein milieu de la ville,
esest un espace fort intéressant
popour nous. La population nous
a a clairement demandé d'en faie
unun parc de conservation pour s
gégénérations futures, alors no,
onon s'est engagés, le conseil
dede ville, on a accepté
cecette position-là.
- - À Beloeil, même si le golf t
totoujours en activité, on ne vt
papas prendre de risques.
NANADINE VIAU, mairesse de Belol
- - Le golf chez nous, à Beloei,
ététait prêt à vendre 5 % de son
esespace pour de la construction
rérésidentielle. Donc là, on est
enen train de voir : est-ce
ququ'il y a d'autres alternativ,
d'd'autres options qu'on pourrat
prproposer qui permettraient
dede pérenniser le sport,
mamais aussi l'espace vert?
- - Les villes attendent avec
imimpatience la réforme de la Li
susur l'expropriation pour pouvr
papayer la valeur marchande
dedes terrains qu'ils souhaitent
prpréserver. À l'heure actuelle,
elelles doivent verser
unun dédommagement qui équivaut
àà la valeur potentielle
quque pourrait avoir un terrain
s's'il entièrement développé.
UnUne facture salée si le terran
enen question appartient
àà un promoteur.
- - Pour nous, c'est inaccessibe
sisi on veut faire donc
l'l'acquisition du terrain,
alalors ce sera une autre étape
ququi va venir.
- - Les maires réclament aussi
10100 millions $ à Québec
popour l'acquisition de terrains
àà protéger.
CHCHANTAL ROULEAU, ministre
reresponsable, région de Montrél
- - Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
tetellement d'objections
àà ce qu'on y arrive.
OnOn le verra dans le prochain
bubudget, évidemment.
- - Québec devra maintenant
apapprouver le règlement
avavant qu'il n'entre en vigueu.
LaLa communauté métropolitaine
dede Montréal indique que d'auts
teterrains de golf et d'autres
sesecteurs qui ont le potentiel
d'd'être reconvertis en espaces
veverts serontnt protégés.
I Ici Olivier Bachandnd,
R Radio-Canada, Candidiac